I was just listening to our annual hate
list you know it's amazing to me I don't
realize I'm doing it at the time but
when I'm talking with Robin over the
course of the year I always say I hate
this I hate that and the guys compiled
it in a list and it's my God I sound so
negative here it is turns out I hate a
lot I hate losing I hate going into
Manhattan I hate the Soviet Union I
don't care about Pirates I hate [ __ ]
Pirates I hate Vikings I hate balloons I
hate parades I hate being tall I hate
the Met Gala I [ __ ] hate Christmas I
hate that the Super Bowl's on at 6 30. I
hate people who sit in an audience and
sing along I hate sitcom so much I hate
jokes I hate gay gifts I kind of hate
myself I hate brothers who write I hate
the burden of like the Happy Birthday
routine mascots are [ __ ] annoying I
hate them I hate to see two bottoms
fighting I hate sprinkles I hate public
pools I hate being told what I have to
watch I hate being criticized I hate
animal abuse I hate being by myself I
wrote three books and I hated it I hate
not being in charge of my own show
did I say sprinkles that I hate
sprinkles I thought I heard that yeah
sprinkles and I do hate sprinkles I hate
them you must be buying shitty ice cream
if you need sprinkles I hate sprinkles I
Do by the way the guys put together a
love list though there were things that
I love things yes I like this 2022 love
list here it is I love radio I love to
talk to the listeners I love my audience
I love [ __ ] anything with a motor
cooler I love Carvel I love little ducks
I love [ __ ] breakfast I love
claymation I love having feet I love
games I love the bachelor so much I love
She-Hulk I love Beavis and Butthead I
love the following shows Lois and Clark
Beverly Hills housewives American Idol
yeah I love peanut butter I love pens I
love people who use big words love
Virginia I love role playing I love
snacks I love sneezing so much I love to
sit by the pool and watch people I love
the New York Times Beetlejuice I love
that guy Bobo I love you I love Fred I
love Sal I love JD Robin of course I
always love you Gary's like a beaver but
uh
and I love you I'm going to give you a
big hug if I ever see you again all
right by the way Robin you will be
pleased to know and this is why I feel
my therapy is working I hated 77 things
this year but I loved a whopping get
ready for this
287 things this year I loved I wondered
what the balance was yeah that's good
yeah that's really good I am proud of
you
oh